[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour cette
émission spéciale élections régionales
et départementales sur france 3 c'est
parti pour trois heures de direct des
résultats des analyses des décryptages
et puis à 20h pile nous vous donnerons à
la première estimation pour ces
régionales
notre sondage à la sortie des urnes m
bonsoir à elsa et sur notre plateau pour
débuter cette soirée électorale patrick
molinoz vice présidents sortants molinos
pardon c'est l'habitude les frais en
franche comté on prononce pas le z
patrick molinoz ce donc élu régional
vice président sortant candidat pour la
liste de marie-guite dufay également sur
ce plateau le député les républicains du
jura jean marie sermier candidat sur la
liste de gilles platret séverine
veillesse porte parole de la france
insoumise pour la campagne et au delà
des quartiers est candidate pour la
liste le temps des cerises parole de
l'ars les exact par bastien photos et
enfin olivier damien candidats de la
liste du rassemblement national en
saône-et-loire liste menée par julien ou
double pour soit admise bon choix
alors nous allons parler sur ce plateau
des régionales et puis nous allons aussi
faire le point sur les élections
départementales et pour ça tout au long
de la soirée nous allons retrouver
catherine ngiri et gabrielle talon
bonsoir à tous les deux bonsoir elsa
bonsoir à tous
en effet gabrielle talon et moi même
nous allons vous parler des
départementales en bourgogne et en
franche comté est tout d'abord la parole
à gabriel quel est le dispositif mis en
place dans nos huit départements et bien
catherine un dispositif exceptionnel
puisque nous serons présents dans les
huit villes préfectures de la région
pour recueillir et bien les réactions
des candidats également vous proposer
des reportages
alors quels sont les enjeux de ces
élections départementales en bourgogne
et en franche comté et bien quelles vont
être les président réélu aussi que
actuellement sur les huit départements
six sont détenus par la droite et 2 par
la bouche
quelles vont être les masses mais les
bascules de droite à gauche ou de gauche
à droite et puis quel score pour leur à
le mont national en effet on s'attend à
des scores élevés pour le rassemblement
national dans l'yonne dans le pays de
montbéliard dans le doubs est également
dans l'est de la haute saône
voilà elsa merci beaucoup catherine
merci gabriel et ya tout à l'heure les
départementales et régionales un scrutin
gérer mais marqué par une très forte
abstention
oui jamais à des élections régionales où
des élections départementales les
français n'avaient ci peut voter c'est
aussi le cas cette année donc pour ce
scrutin une abstention record
votre première réaction à ce à cette
abstention massive des électeurs jean
marie sermier
d'abord on sort d'une crise sanitaire et
un certain nombre de personnes peuvent
aujourd'hui craindre encore pour leur
santé et puis il faut le reconnaître une
inorganisation complète du scrutin et
notamment la distribution des
professions de foi des bulletins de vote
et quelquefois des bulletins de vote
dans les communes qui ont fait que plus
personne ne s'y retrouver et évidemment
je crois aujourd'hui qu'on n'a pas fait
en sorte la responsabilité de l'état est
engagée sur le fait qu' on n'a pas
assuré à cette élection
les moyens de réussir suffisamment fort
à mobiliser les gens c'est la vitesse
vous êtes d'accord
alors je suis d'accord pour dire que
l'abstention est un fait politique
depuis un certain nombre d'années donc
ça c'est déjà une réalité
il faut se poser des questions quand on
n'a plus du deux tiers des citoyens des
citoyens qui ne se déplacent plus pour
participer à la décision de la cidh
mais comment j'explique que je
l'expliqué notamment par le fait que ça
fait 30 ans qu'on trompe les électeurs
et que quelque part que ce soit un
gouvernement de droite ou de gauche
ce sont les mêmes politiques libérales
qui ont été menées et qui on se met la
misère et qui font aujourd'hui qu'on a
une extrême droite assez forte
et puis il ya aussi cette
désorganisation totale il faudra en
tirer les conséquences au plus haut
sommet de l'état avec un ministre de
l'intérieur gérard d'armagnac a été
totalement incapable d'organiser ces
élections
à cette heure on a plus de la moitié des
électeurs de bourgogne franche comté qui
n'ont pas reçu la propagande est certain
c'est brive éléments jouent gros à paris
les 20 heures on allait oui la première
estimation gérer mine pour notre région
oui la première estimation ipsos steria
notre partenaire partenaires de france
télévisions pour cette soirée électorale
et vous allez
voir elle va s'afficher estimations
sorties des urnes c'est une surprise
estimation qui balaye tout alors déjà on
voit l'abstention quasiment 66 %
d'abstention dans notre région quasiment
au niveau de l'abstention attendue au
niveau national et puis les résultats
donc qui contredisent tous les sondages
réalisés pendant la campagne électorale
c'est marie-guite dufay qui basculerait
en tête de ce premier tour avec 26,2
pour cent des suffrages marie-guite
dufay qui était troisième du premier
tour lors de la dernière élection
régionale
suivent dans l'ordre julien houle 23,8 %
gilles platret 20,9 pour cent et denis
thuriau 12,7 pour cent ses quatre listes
sont en position de se maintenir pour le
second tour elles dépassent le seuil des
10 % suivent
stéphanie modde 9 9% aura donc des 10%
fatidique
stéphanie modde qui peut éventuellement
fusionner avec l'une des listes qui a
dépassé les 10%
puis bastien faudot 4,1 pour cent et
claire rocher de lutte ouvrière 2 4%
séverine bs je reviens vers vous 4,1
pour cent c'est une gêne âgées une
grosse déception ce soir on va déjà
rester prudent parce que pour l'instant
ce sont des estimations et au regard des
taux d'abstention important je pense
qu'il faut rester serein et attendre de
voir les résultats consolidés
après je vais pas vous dire le contraire
si les résultats se confirment
évidemment qu'on est déçu quand on mène
une campagne c'est pour gagner c'est
pour porter des idéaux
voilà donc je vais pas vous dire le
contraire ce soir évidemment patrick
molinoz est ce que ce n'est pas un
résultat inespéré pour la majorité
sortante
d'abord pardon mais je veux revenir sur
la participation nous aviez commencé à
interroger tout à l'heure pour dire que
je pense pas qu'il faille crier au loup
nous étions un certain nombre est assez
défavorable à cette date pour l'élection
parce que nous savions d'emblée en tout
cas certains le pensaient que
techniquement la situation sanitaire
risquait d'avoir le même effet qu'elle a
eu l'année dernière pour les municipales
ça n'a pas manqué mais en plus comme
cela a été dit moi je parle de sabotage
réellement de sabotage
quant à la non distribution de la
propagande officielle et ça ça touche
l'ensemble des forces politiques quelles
que soient les programmes qu'ils
défendent
c'est d'abord pour ces raisons
techniques par non celle la situation
sanitaire puis celle de ce sabotage
démocratique
je demande si c'est pas organisé par le
ministère de l'intérieur dans la commune
quasiment personne n'a reçu la
propagande pour les régionales donc on a
déjà cette difficulté pour le résultat
il est 20 heures et quelques minutes il
faut raison garder évidemment on préfère
à 20 heures être premier qu'être plus
loin il faut attendre le dépouillement
complet pour pouvoir voir qu'elle est
réel quels sont réellement les
équilibres politiques dans la région
mais c'est plutôt le signe d'une
reconnaissance du travail conduit par
marie-guite dufay sa majorité
alors puisqu'on évoque justement
marie-guite dufay
on vous l'a dit on va être tout au long
de la soirée au plus près des candidats
on va tout de suite parti en préfecture
emmanuel rivals 1 emmanuel rivals 1 qui
se trouve justement avec marie-guite
dufay les manuels j'imagine que
l'ambiance est plutôt bonne proposer une
première réaction de marie-guite dufay
qui n'est toujours pas arrivé ici en
préfecture de dijon où elle est attendue
pour prendre connaissance des premiers
résultats consolidés lorsque je peux
vous dire c'est qu'on arrive dufay a
voté ce matin dans sa ville à besançon
et elle a eu cette petite phrase comme
un aveu elle nous a dit tout simplement
je n'ai pas su rassembler la gauche
toute la gauche
et bien tout commence ce soir
effectivement tout commence ce soir dans
un état de désunion à gauche amplifié
sans doute par l'abstention mais vous
l'avez dit les résultats semblent être
favorable des négociations vont
commencer dans la soirée dans un premier
temps le ps va se rassembler pour savoir
qui va laisser sa place à d'éventuels
nouveaux entrants et puis vers 22h 23h
et bien il y aura cette triangulation
avec les alliés naturels de la gauche de
marie-guite dufay recevoir les
écologistes et le temps des cerises la
soirée risque d'être longue
ici à dijon et une soirée que vous allez
suivre pour nous merci beaucoup emmanuel
arrive alain olivier damien
réaction d'abord peut-être cette
abstention record et puis au score du
rassemblement national qui était attendu
beaucoup plus haut qu'il ne l'est et qui
vraisemblablement aphatie lui aussi de
cette forte abstention
bien sûr alors moi je voudrais quand
même remercier les électeurs qui sont
déplacés parce que on parle de ceux qui
n'y sont pas allés moi je remercie tous
les électeurs qui ont fait cet effort là
et aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
c'est important que c'est un geste
citoyen on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
peut-être ultérieurement
en ce qui concerne les résultats autour
de ce plateau c'est ce que tout le monde
dit il faut attendre un petit peu pour
voir comment les choses vont avancer
dans la soirée si effectivement ça se
confirme c'est clair que nous aurons un
gros travail au deuxième tour pour
sensibiliser à nouveau notre électorat
pour bien leur faire comprendre quelle
est l'importance de ce scrutin
quelle importance l'importance du
message toulon portes que le lin or
expliqué ce soir cette abstention c'est
une campagne qui n'a pas déchaîné les
passions c'est les mauvaises campagnes
comme vous
non non je préfère dire une mauvaise
campagne je pense d'abord qu'il ya un
contexte que l'on n'a été décrit qui a
eu ce qui a eu s'engage sur l'importance
je pense que effectivement les
dysfonctionnements majeurs
on a vu des ministres allait faire
campagne il aurait mieux fait de
s'occuper des élections je pense au
ministre de l'intérieur en particulier à
partir de là c'est vrai que les jeux
étaient fausses et forcément et je crois
que ça à deux une incidence évidente sur
le sur les résultats que nous allons
observer ce soir ceci étant dit c'est le
premier tour voilà nous allons nous
organiser nous allons analyser ces
résultats nous allons voir comment on
peut organiser ce deuxième tour organisé
la riposte et voir comment on peut nous
mobiliser notre électorat qui
manifestement si les résultats se
confirment le une fois de plus je le dis
si les résultats se confirment c'est
vrai qu'il faudra faire un effort dans
ce sens là alors justement on va filer
tout de suite à dijon dans le qg
justement de julien odoul la tête de
liste du rassemblement national valentin
nous attend sur place valentin quelle
est l'ambiance dans le dans le camp
julien houle est bien assez calme pour
l'instant en fait il n'est pas encore
descendu il est attendu d'ici 20h30 pour
réagir à ces résultats justement par
contre julian d'où le candidat du
rassemblement national est descendu à
s'est brièvement il y à quelques minutes
seulement pour prononcé ces propos la
température est incertaine
on attend on attend de savoir en fait si
c'est une grosse désillusion ou non pour
le candidat du rassemblement national
qui je vous le rappelle était crédité de
28% des voix dans le dernier sondage
il devait être en tête selon ce même
sondage est là il arriverait en seconde
position derrière la présidente sortante
une grosse désillusion également car
comparé au résultat de 2015 aux
dernières élections régionales le rn
perdrait du terrain à l'époque sophie
montel la candidate cdu et rennes
avaient réalisé 31 % des voix au premier
tour et avait pas forcément réussi à
l'emporter au second tour où je voulais
dit julien houle est attendu ici d'ici
20h30 pour réagir à ces résultats on
viendra pouvoir merci beaucoup valentin
chatelier et on va rester extrêmement
prudent puisque ce sont des estimations
j'aime bien
alors olivier damien effectivement on le
on le rappeler avec notre envoyé spécial
au quartier général de julien houle
il y avait les sondages mais il ya aussi
les faits c'est ce score de 31 et demi
pour cent des suffrages la dernière fois
lors des dernières régionales en 2015
vous êtes estimé ce soir par notre
partenaire ipsos osteria à 8 points de
moins ça veut dire que vous avez perdu
énormément d'électorat entre ces deux
scrutins
alors on va voir on va voir les points
demain on va voir bon si c'est un recul
ce sera à nous d'en tirer les
conclusions de waroux où le bât a blessé
ou peut-être nos messages ne sont pas
passés je rappelle également que 2015
c'est un autre contexte
je rappelle qu'à l'époque la république
en marche n'existe pas s'émeut françois
hollande quelques précieuses et lecteurs
sata retient la république en même temps
ils sont pas partis forcément la
république en marche m'enfin le paysage
politique a changé
et à partir de là on modifie le paysage
politique forcément aussi susceptible de
modifier les comportements électoraux de
la même façon que l'impact que la
période que nous venons de traverser sur
cette campagne est évident de dire on
peut pas on peut pas le nier
pardon moi je crois c'est une élection
ce qui est incomprise je crois que il y
aura des meilleurs il y aura
nécessairement
les messages de clarification à faire
par rapport à ce que est ce que portent
ces élections ce qu'elle signifie je
pense qu'il faut que notre aval a trick
domino le disait vous n'êtes pas
forcément les premiers à parler du coeur
des compétences de la région
alors nous en avons parlé nous avons
nous avons fait quand même un certain
nombre de propositions dans différents
domaines on peut pas dire que ce soit
écartée du sujet les banques c'est
parler d'eux c'est que les normes et
donc alors moi je vous pose la question
on dit suffisamment que c est cette
élection n'intéresse personne
si on n'avait pas parlé d'un sujet qui
intéresse quand même les français on en
serait aujourd'hui la sécurité est un
sujet nous l'assumons nous assumons ce
choix-là parler de certains sujets c'est
à sylvie mellies mais je regrette je
regrette c'est à la des compétences
évidente par le biais de serre d'un
levier je le maintiens je le hais je le
dis très fort maintenant c'est sûr que
je pense que nos bons citoyens n'ont pas
été intéressés par cette campagne
allez autre chose en nous de bonnes
questions autre liste qui a mis la
sécurité en avant c'est la vôtre jean
marie sermier
donc je rappelle 1 le sondage sortie des
urnes
vous êtes à peu près à 21% quel regard
vous portez sur ce niveau ce score a
coûté d'abord il faut conforter tous ces
résultats en cours de soirée puisque
vous savez qu'il ya une petite
différence quand même entre le votant
campagne et le vote dans les villes et
qu'on n'a pas dans les premières
estimations
forcément l'ensemble de la
représentation ça c'est prévu points le
deuxième point c'est que partout en
france on constate une poussée très
forte des sortants parce qu'évidemment
les régions évidemment quand vous avez
une campagne qui a été un peu mis sous
éteignoir à cause de la crise sanitaire
sur lesquels d'ailleurs pourrait causer
beaucoup sur la capacité d'avoir des
réunions que nous a refusé et qui aurait
pu expliquer à nos concitoyens les
compétences de la région et des
départements où ce qui concerne
l'hébergement
donc quand on est dans cette logique de
nos campagnes forcément le sortant est
plus cool de contes et chants qu'on
souhaite oui les chatons ce thème que
pour les quelques chiffres que j'ai au
niveau français partout ailleurs les
sortants fond
pratiquement 20% de plus qu'ils n'ont
fait autrefois mais parfois y en à
droite et l'auvergne rhône-alpes et je
crois que le sortant laurent wauquiez
est pas loin de 40 5% et car les aviez
bertrand est aussi aux alentours de 45
46% à gauche c'est aussi le cas d'alain
rousset aidé et je constate que
finalement c'est en bourgogne franche
comté que la prime au sortant est la
plus faible
ce qui veut dire que tout est encore à
jouer et madame du fai avait raison ce
matin quand elle disait que tout
commençait ce soir tout commence
réellement ce soir et je crois que il va
falloir qu'on mobilise l'ensemble de nos
électeurs nous sommes et où nous le sait
bien la seule liste d'alternance à la
gauche socialiste et bien on
l'expliquera pendant la semaine qui va
se dérouler mais néanmoins jean marie
sermier d'ordinaire c'est la droite qui
mobilise davantage là ce soir c'est pas
le cas en bourgogne franche comté où est
passé votre électorat est parti à la
pêche
non non rassurez vous notre électorat il
est comme tous les électorats ils se
sont posé des questions peut être aussi
que un certain nombre de personnes âgées
incertaine de personnes de la ruralité
sont moins venus voter qu'il ne venait
traditionnellement si on va aller on va
l'immobiliser au cours des semaines à
venir parce que je vous le dis on n'a
pas pu faire les rencontres notre nos
campagnes à droite elle s'assume
complètement elle s'assume complètement
sûr du terrain alors avec gilles platret
on a fait beaucoup de terrain
probablement d'ailleurs que nous sommes
la liste qui avons fait le plus de
terrain mais pas encore suffisamment et
on va continuer dans la semaine qui va
venir patrick molinoz sûr sûr sûr les
résultats ce soir et sur l'après on
entendait tout à l'heure et manel
rivalland dire que des discussions
allaient s'engager avec les autres
listes de gauche est ce que vous
confirmez
on attend totalité des résultats est
effectivement marini tard indiqué depuis
le début de la campagne qu'il entendait
rassembler la gauche nous sommes le
rempart le seul rempart en bourgogne
franche comté à l'arrivée du roi
sûrement nationale
soit mais rappelez-vous 2015 2015 nous
sommes arrivés troisièmes nous avons
gagné
je vous dois interrompre une super mais
oui mais moi je vous dis à griller cette
correction va nous la vérité c'est que
nous étions arrivés troisièmes que nous
avons gagné nous avons été les remparts
en 2015 et que là nous avons vu que
l'arc que la mine au stade nous sommes
trois points nous sommes trois dans les
formules juste on peut le regarder les
chiffres tels qu'ils sont à cette heure
ci et nous verrons 23 heures d'élections
qui se situe à servir si je vous laissez
moi vous messieurs s'est remis ça n'est
pas très correct et je pense que si vous
avez ces résultats cette façon de faire
de la politique qui agace nos
concitoyens disons la vérité
regardons simplement ce que sont des
résultats à cette heure ci je vous en
donne à une estimation françois rebsamen
elle somme que marie-guite dufay serait
à 32% dans la ville de dijon 6
marie-guite dufay est à 32 pour cent de
la ville de dijon ce sera notamment
grâce à l'engagement de françois
rebsamen derrière une autre liste avec
notre liste c'est extrêmement important
et ça pèsera lourd sur le résultat final
donc je réaffirme ce servier que nous
sommes le rempart contre le front
national nous progressons à cette heure
ci par rapport à 2015 et vous régressez
et le front national régresse savez bien
que ça n'ait de regarder les chiffres
en 2015 il n'y avait pas la république
en marche donc ça veut dire que le
paysage électoral a changé donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes qu'à la vie au
lycée c'est vrai au sol avant de faire
une petite compagnie voulait
l'interrompt avec des unités si vous
parlez les deux en même temps ne vous
comprends rien en gros ça c'est vrai
séverine vieillesse est ce que la gauche
va parler à la gauche ce soir mais nous
on a toujours dit depuis le début qu'on
était pour le rassemblement de la gauche
et des écologistes et on a fait ça
depuis le début donc voila nous on est
là gauche sincère clair on l'a toujours
dit on fera on fera ce qu'on avait dit
que les tractations ont commencé déjà
alors moi je voudrais revenir sur un
point
comment sait on a on a eu des échanges
mal discuté des discussions dans jusqu'à
hier soir
mais moi je rêve ni sur sur un élément
quand même gère l'organisation de cette
élection on est quand même face à une
crise d'état qui est quand même
phénoménal et il faut qu'on en tire les
conséquences pour les prochains scrutins
il faut pas oublier que adrexo qu'est la
société privée qui a eu le monopole pour
dans un certain nombre de régions pour
organes
ise pour désorganiser cette élection et
celle qui est prévue pour les élections
présidentielles de l'année prochaine
donc c'est encore une fois là on voit
bien un exemple de l'échec de la mise en
concurrence d'un service public
une entreprise privée n'est pas capable
de gérer une mission de service public
il faut que les libéraux en tirent les
conséquences ce soir et ce discours là
il ne porte pas dans les urnes
aujourd'hui
non mais moi je parle des fins non mais
votre discours il je veux dire que la
l'estimation c'est moins de 5 pour finir
mais pendant la campagne on apportait on
apporter un programme là moi je suis en
train de vous parler de ce qui s'est
passé ces derniers jours avec la
distribution de la propagande c'est deux
choses différentes oui mais c'est la
question de la privatisation des
services publics
oui mais force est de constater les
faits une montre que ça ne fonctionne
pas donc je pense aussi dans cette
élection il ya eu un vote utile qui
s'est mis en place on ne peut pas l'on
peut pas le nier et que le fait que le
gouvernement installe une dualité entre
le rassemblement
le rassemblement pardon le rassemblement
national et le reste du monde fait à un
moment donné ben oui les électeurs se
sont mobilisés dans le cadre d'un vote
utile
alors vous me parlez de la république en
marche qu'allez-vous faire avec la
république en marche patrick molinoz
zeiss que vous allez discuter avec denis
thuriau qui a fait des appels du pied à
marie-guite dufay assez flagrant lors du
débat que nous avons organisée il ya une
dizaine de jours denis curio a dit qu'il
serait intelligent par rapport aux
risques rassemblement national moi je ne
pas parler à la place de la route de
nick huriaux nous souhaitons rassembler
la gauche et toute la gauche
nous attendons d'avoir la totalité des
résultats ce n'était effectivement pas
la même chose si nos alliés naturels
sont à 12 à 8 à 5
mais les résultats nous dirons en tout
cas on a besoin d'eux dans l'esprit dans
tous les cas une liste qui fera moins de
cinq n'a pas la possibilité légale de
rentrer avec nous dans le dispositif
ça ne veut pas dire que leurs électeurs
vont aller à la pêche qui prendre le
risque que le rn repasse devant au
dernier instant
la mobilisation doit rester complète
jusqu'à dimanche 27 à 19 heures le
dernier domino est ce que vous souhaitez
soyons clairs est-ce que vous souhaitez
qu'il y ait des écologistes des
candidats de la liste de stéphanie modde
sur la liste de mme arguer du fait la
semaine prochaine nous nous souhaitons
que la
gauche emporte nous sommes le
rassemblement de la gauche dès le départ
avec les trois partis historiques de la
gauche le parti radical de gauche le
parti communiste le parti socialiste et
nous échangeons tout à fait librement et
en construction nous avons pas
exactement la même ligne que et les
filles ça va sans dire mais nous sommes
dans la même grande famille nous ne
partageons pas exactement la même ligne
que tous les verts cela va sans dire
mais nous sommes dans la même grande
famille attendons d'avoir les résultats
et mettons nous un ordre de marche pour
mobiliser et que marie-guite dufay qui
est un bilan exceptionnel puisse
continuer pendant ce mandat
entre résultats variés en toute mesure
je suis un peu de partis pris soin de
ses vice-présidents c'est normal que je
défende selon ce bilan
merci beaucoup je vous propose qu'on
poursuive notre tournée des quartiers
généraux et cette fois c'est avec
christophe taris qui nous attend
christophe tarissant diack vous êtes
christophe vous avec gilles platret
alors est ce que le candidat ait l'air
est arrivé de sa ville de chalon déjà et
bien gilles platret toujours à la mairie
de chalon il est arrivé à l'hôtel de
ville peu avant 19 heures il a assisté
au premier dépouillement dans les
bureaux de l'hôtel de ville puis après
il s'est enfermé dans son bureau de
maire pour suivre les premiers résultats
est allé lecture de ce s'il ya un petit
peu de surprises on ça sentait qu être
bien plus haut il a reçu un message de
félicitations d'alain joyandet dit
félicitant de son score en haute saône
il est aussi très haut en saône et loire
est ici même évidemment à chalon mais sa
troisième classe laisse un petit goût
amer ici il devrait quitter très
prochainement ses bureaux de maire de
chalon pour rejoindre un hôtel dijonnais
où il doit suivre la soirée avec
d'autres têtes de liste pour affiner
évidemment sa campagne du deuxième tour
et sa stratégie merci beaucoup
christophe taris et parmi les
interlocuteurs de gilles platret y aura
très certainement jean marie saint mais
qui a souri à cette évocation un goût
amer disait christophe taris c'est vous
le partager ce goût amer nous nous
s'attendait à être dans ces niveaux de
résultat la l'espérions la tuilerie à
méplat subtilise la surprise vient
effectivement que le rn
et très bas par rapport aux annonces
mais vous savez moi j'ai fait un certain
nombre de législatives et en 2010 est la
différence entre les résultats c'était
plus 10 points entre le premier et le
deuxième tour c'était aux régionales en
dominant donc il faut être très mesurées
très patient moi je vous le dis je vous
le répète nous sommes la seule liste en
capacité à pouvoir faire une alternative
à la liste de gauche dont on a bien
compris qu'elle souhaitait avoir une
position encore plus dur à gauche
puisque il souhaite avoir
et les filles avec eux eh bien nous on
invite tous les bourguignons ils
souhaitent vraiment vers une alternative
à madame du fait ce bilan qui est loin
d'être exceptionnel et avoir une région
un peu plus charismatiques de venir nous
rejoindre les cieux sermier juste pour
vous répondre la liste le temps des
cerises est une liste de rassemblement
de neuf organisations politiques dont
générations et dont la france a soumise
par contre vous fait alliance avec
debout la france donc par des me
pardonnez moi mais l'extrême et les
cheveux du goût cause
je vous propose qu'on poursuive ce débat
dans quelques minutes on va prendre la
direction
on va se rendre tout de suite vers
catherine émigrés et gabrielle talon
pour faire un point sur les élections
départementales cet avocat très oui
merci à re bonsoir à tous pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent en effet maintenant on
va parler des départementales donc il y
a huit départements en bourgogne franche
comté
s'ils sont à droite deux sont à gauche
et gabriel nous allons tout car c'est
dans un instant nous irons gabriel en
saône et loire puis en côte d'or mais
tout de suite ont rejoint quand un cas
rude elle quitte en direct de lons le
saunier la ville préfecture du jura a
donc des départements qui est à droite
quentin quels sont les enjeux dans ce
département eh bien oui les enjeux dans
le jura sont multiples du côté de la
république en marche les deux binômes de
la majorité présidentielle n'ont pas
vraiment nos positions de la part de la
gauche et de la droite traditionnelle
alors simple coïncidence ou accord de
principe pour la droite majoritaire au
conseil départemental il n'y a pas
vraiment de suspense non plus la preuve
le président sortant clément pernot seul
candidat dans son canton de champagnole
est donc sûre d'être réélue
entre la gauche aussi l'union est
difficile puisque quelques binôme se
sont constitués ils ont été battus en
2015 ils sont minoritaires au conseil
départemental depuis six ans alors la
gauche espèrent maintenant reconquérir
sa place
il y aura aussi le rassemblement
national puisque le rassemblement
national risque de jouer les arbitres
entre la gauche et la droite dans neuf
cantons sur 17
merci quand un merci quentin 12 nous
allons maintenant à belfort retrouver
emilien diaz donc le département du
territoire de belfort est aussi un
département à droite le jour à dos
clément pernot et divers droite florian
bouquet c'est le président ait l'air du
territoire de belfort et emilien
qu'elles sont donc aussi les enjeux les
rapports de force entre la droite la
gauche et peut-être le rassemblement
national dans le territoire de belfort
bonsoir catherine mais bien tout d'abord
il faut préciser qu ici on est dans le
plus petit département de la région neuf
cantons 18 représentants et à élire au
conseil du département donc l'importance
des des cantons aujourd'hui qu'ils vont
pouvoir faire basculer la majorité d'un
côté ou d'un autre ça va être très
important sur ce scrutin est en jeu il
est surtout pour les républicains qui
l'ont emporté en 2015
florian bouquet vous l'avez dit le
président actuel qui se représente sur
son canton de châtenois les forges où il
va faire face à un duel avec le
rassemblement national
le rassemblement national aussi on peut
en parler puisque il est faiblement
présent sur cette élection avec deux
candidats enfin deux candidatures dans
deux cantons c'est 7 de moins qu'en 2015
il aura donc un vrai rapport de force
entre les républicains le rassemblement
national la gauche aussi qui veut qui
voudra tirer son épingle du jeu dans
certains cantons où elle est présente
voilà les enjeux ici dans le territoire
de belfort pour ce premier tour
merci emilien je donne la parole
maintenant à gabrielle talon pour les
départements de bourgogne et gabriel
vous nous emmenez tout d'abord c'est pas
vous qui allez tout de suite mais en
saône et loire
en saône-et-loire oui puisque le
département avait basculé en 2015 un
passant de lagos à la droite le
président divers droite autres hakkari
est candidat à sa réélection
et on retrouve tout de suite à la
préfecture de mâcon florence donjon
[Musique]
président sortant andré accary part
favori fort de son bilan notamment en
matière de santé la majorité
départementale est présente dans la
plupart des cantons
face à lui l'opposition avance en ordre
plus que dispersés pour preuve certains
élus de gauche dont le maire de gueugnon
dominique lotte anciens partis
socialistes entendent bien faire réélire
andré accary et se sont reliés à sa
cause
un soutien qui en dit long sur l'état de
la gauche dans le département
fracture est dispersée elle est
totalement absente dans six comptons sur
29 au total l'objectif en revanche est
atteint pour le rassemblement national
qui est présent sur tout le département
de la saône et loire est la saône et
loire est un département qui semble être
le reflet de la vie politique nationale
je vous le rappelle le département était
dirigée jusqu'en 2015 à part la gauche
sous la présidence d'arnaud montebourg
merci donc gabriel maintenant autres
départements donc de bourgogne vous nous
emmenez en côte d'or oui la côte d'or
présidé par lui dis donc françois
sauvadet rove a tout de suite retrouvé à
la préfecture de dijon
anne berger anne et de quels sont les
enjeux de ce scrutin et puis est ce que
parce que l'on a déjà des premiers
résultats des premiers éléments
notamment sur la participation
alors il va falloir attendre un petit
peu pour avoir la participation
définitive ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
ce qui caractérise la côte d'or c'est sa
stabilité le département est à droite
depuis les années 80 et en 2015 elle
avait encore renforcé ses positions
elle détient 14 cantons sur 23 va-t-elle
conserver cet avantage et bien c'est
toute la question
surtout après la confusion qui est venu
semer dans son camp l'autre scrutin
celui des régionales puisque deux
vice-présidentes ci présente sur deux
listes opposées
l'unc sur la liste de droite de gilles
platret l'autre sur celle de la
république en marche qui aligne par
ailleurs 9 bis
comme pour ce premier tour mais bien sûr
c'est surtout le score du rassemblement
national qui va être scrutée en côte
d'or en 2015 il s'était qualifié pour le
second tour dans seize cantons sur 23
arrivé en tête dans trois cantons le
parti de marine le pen va t'il cette
fois pouvoir faire son entrée dans
l'assemblée départementale c'est aussi
l'un des enjeux de ce scrutin
merci anne on va maintenant prendre la
direction de la nièvre pour retrouver
rémy fidèles à nevers
rémy bonsoir audi que lors de cette
élection le parti socialiste pourrait
être menacé
voyez alors pour l'instant la seule
certitude c'est que le département ouvre
un nouveau président à l'issue de ce
scrutin
alain a su en poste depuis 2000 17 a
choisi de passer la main la question qui
se pose c'est de savoir donc s'il aura
un successeur issus de la majorité
socialiste à la tête du département
depuis plus de 60 ans ou si le
changement de personnes sera aussi
l'occasion d'un basculement du
département en 2015 la gauche avait été
menacée mais avait réussi à emporter 10
cantons sur dix est cette fois l'
équilibre semble plus précaire encore le
rassemblement national est aussi en
embuscade pour en espérant profiter de
sa progression lors des dernières
élections pour faire son entrée au sein
de l'assemblée départementale
reste à savoir si la participation bien
plus faible qu'en 2015 sera favorable
aux sortants ou si cela pourrait
favoriser des surprises
merci rémi chidaine on va maintenant
prendre la direction de l'yonne et on va
aller à auxerre retrouver sébastien
kérou sébastien il devrait pas y avoir
beaucoup de suspense la droite devrait
garder la majorité
oui tout à fait un gabriel parce que
d'après les premiers résultats qu'on a
pu recevoir il ya seulement quelques
minutes
et bien la droite l'emporterait dans 16
cantons des 21 contre le que compte le
département de l'yonne
à noter que patrick patrick gendraud
l'actuel président du conseil
départemental de l'yonne a été est
arrivé largement en tête dans son
comptant de chablis et puis concernant
la gauche eh bien elle partait unis dans
ces élections départementales mail
arrivé en tête que dans un seul canton
c'est celui de joie ni avec frédéric
colas est à noter que le rassemblement
national qui arrive en tête également
dans deux cantons ceux de torigni sur
rezé coeur de puisaye pour l'instant
donc la droite semble confirmer son
hégémonie sur le département de l'yonne
ces résultats ne sont que partielles
bien entendu merci beaucoup nous allons
maintenant dans le territoire de belfort
au à belfort même on nous attend florian
bouquet qui est le président des
républicains donc de du conseil
départemental du territoire monsieur
bouquet est ce que vous m'entendez
bonsoir à vous oui vous entendant
quatrième devant soir bonsoir
je vais vous poser une question bête est
ce que vous avez déjà des résultats
parce que là il est 20 heures 28 et nous
n'avons pratiquement pas de résultats
quelle est la tendance qui se dessine
dans votre département
et bien tout d'abord nous avons sur le
canton châtenois-les-forges par exemple
où je suis le conseiller départemental
sortant la question il nous reste encore
à dépouiller quelques communes mais il
semblerait que je sois pas loin d'être
réduit au premier tour avec un peu plus
de 70% des voix sur le canton de
grandvillars mon candidat alexandre
mansanné est bien placé aussi pour le
hêtre qualifier au deuxième tour contre
le conseiller départemental sortant sur
le secteur de delvaux kourou le sénateur
du territoire de belfort cédric perrin
était candidat là encore il y à de
belles perspectives
il semblerait qu'un deuxième tour soit
nécessaire mais il est seul candidat sur
ce canton là mais un deuxième tour sera
nécessaire une faute d'avoir atteint le
seuil des 25% des inscrits et puis sur
le secteur de rougemont château
giromagny au nord du territoire de
belfort
eh bien mon candidat didier valverde est
très bien placé
largement en tête des candidats oui là
c'était donc un binôme de gauche qui
étaient sortants et qui ne se
représentait pas donc là vous nous
annoncez que monsieur albert du donc est
en tête dans ce département c'est très
important
il est très largement en tête mais à
deuxième tour sera nécessaire pour pour
confirmer ce choix est donc les
électeurs sont bien évidemment appelés à
renouveler leur choix et puis à
l'amplifier dimanche prochain sur le
canton
et puis je n'ai encore pas suffisamment
de précision sur le canton de valdoie
offemont ou la conseillère
départementale sortante marie france et
fils est en tête pour l'instant au
regard des résultats du dépouillement et
sur la ville de belfort plutôt bien vous
avez l'air d'être un homme plutôt serein
voilà exactement
alors si vous voulez rien n'est fait
puisque les dépouillements ne sont pas
totalement achevées ici ou là dans le
territoire de belfort on y verra un peu
plus clair d'ici une heure et enfin bien
un deuxième tour sera nécessaire mais
deuxième tour les compteurs sont remis à
zéro donc il faut aussi que les
électeurs qui se sont déplacés
aujourd'hui renouvellent leur leur choix
oui oui je vous remercie alors dans le
territoire de belfort on totalise kamba
peu plus de participation que partout en
france
bon très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
bouquet je vais donner maintenant la
parole à gabrielle talon parce que les
propos de florian bouquet ont pu
apparaître à certains d'entre vous un
petit peu obscur dit il
il est arrivé premier très largement à
70%
mais il sera pas éluder ce soir donc
gabriel
juste un mot pour nous expliquer comment
fonctionne ce mode de scrutin
départemental pour qu'un candidat même
tout seul
ou alors avec deux binômes sur son
canton est très largement en tête
n'arrive pas à être élu dès le dimanche
20 juin alors catherine pour être élu au
premier tour de ce scrutin mais en fait
il faut respecter deux conditions la
première à voir bien évidemment là
à majorité absolue autre mode il a la
moitié des voix plus une
mais également il faut avoir recueilli 2
25% des inscrits dont 90 un quart des
inscrits est bien évidemment plus
l'abstention est forte plus le
pourcentage de suffrages exprimés que
vous devez avoir supérieur par exemple
si on prend une abstention à 40%
il vous faudra recueillir 62 5% des
suffrages exprimés pour être élu au
premier tour il est fort au matin quand
même il est très très fort merci gabriel
pour cet éclairage
on va maintenant dans le doubs au
kursaal à besançon pour retrouver
stéphanie bonjour stéphanie et quelle
est l'ambiance au kursaal c'est la
question qu'on pose toujours lors des
élections parce que au kursaal c'est
quand même le le pouls de la gauche qui
bat là-bas et que se passe-t-il ce soir
eh bien le kursaal pour l'instant est
interdit au public un beau le voyait
derrière moi seuls les présidents de
bureaux de vote viennent déposer leurs
enveloppes et donc pour l'instant
l'ambiance est un peu particulière pas
de public juste des élus ou des
candidats qui attendent leur tour
vous le savez malgré une parenthèse de
onze ans à gauche sur le département du
doubs est un département résolument
historiquement la dédier à la droite
l'actuel président zeller christine
bouquin qui gouverne avec une
confortable majorité de 26 sièges sur 38
inutile de vous dire donc le suspense
ici n'est pas particulièrement poignant
d'autant que la gauche dont on parlait à
l'instant avance divisée plusieurs
cantons sont ce soir le théâtre de
luttes fratricides c'est le cas à bavans
audincourt bethoncourt et valentigney la
droite également affiche quelques
dissensions quelques querelles internes
mais dans une moindre mesure dans trois
cantons seulement dans celui des besoins
sont cinq non en fait le véritable enjeu
ce soir c'est de savoir si leur
assemblée nationale jusqu'à présent
absent de l'assemblée départementale
parviendra à décrocher un ou plusieurs
tickets le rassemblement national qui
fidèle à sa stratégie
quelle honte des binômes partout et
rappelons qu'en 2015 il était taillé
s'était qualifié pour le second tour
dans 14 des 19 cantons réalisant parfois
des coups des scores supérieurs à 30 %
notamment dans le pays de montbéliard
merci stéphanie nous allons maintenant à
vesoul pour le département de la haute
saône là aussi on scrutera avec beaucoup
d'attention le score du rassemblement
national sur ce département c'est de
plus le dernier département à gauche
en franche comté son président c'est le
divers gauche et il vaut krattinger
frédéric buridan qu'elle est
quels sont les enjeux dans ce
département alors venez de le dire à
catherine le principal enjeu dans ce
département va être bien justement
l'avenir du président actuel yves
krattinger 1 qui se représente est face
à lui il a eu le sénateur et ancien
maire de vesoul alain joyandet qui s'est
lancé aussi dans la course donc on a pu
assister à un duel entre les deux est
derrière tout ça vous l'avez dit
le rassemblement national qui espère
bien jouer les trouble-fêtes nous avons
eu au téléphone tout à l'heure son
leader dans le département qui apparaît
confiant dans les premiers chiffres
qu'il a pu avoir dans les 34 cantons que
compte le département de la haute saône
merci frédéric buridan donc en direct de
vesoul maintenant gabriel nous allons
dans l'yonne un oui où nous attend à
auxerre le
président sortant du conseil
départemental patrick gendraud patrick
gendraud bonsoir bonsoir battu d'abord
est-ce que vous avez vous des premiers
résultats pouvoir nous donner
alors écoutez les premiers résultats que
je peux vous donner ce sont ce qui
concerne mon canton de chablis puisque
j'arrive à l'instant c'est le plus grand
canton du département 62 communes
donc j'ai la quasi totalité des
résultats et nous sommes avec ma
collègue sylvie champignons en tête
largement en tête et suivis je crois du
rassemblement national je n'ai pas les
résultats encore définitif mais nous
sommes en tête malgré une abstention
quand même qui est très importante mais
qui malheureusement n'est pas spécial à
au département de l'yonne je me réjouis
quand même d'avoir obtenu 70% des
suffrages exprimés
est-ce que vous avez les autres villes
de chablis est à l'essai du département
on dit que les candidats de la droite et
du centre pour être en tête dans 19 des
21 cantons alors j'avais comme élément
il y a cinq minutes environ 16 à 17
cantons donc là vous me dites dix neuf
voiliers je n'ai vraiment pas tous les
résultats puisque il ya encore des
communes notamment à auxerre à sens où
on n'a pas les résultats définitifs mais
je crois effectivement que
nous nous sommes sur la bonne voie en
tout cas la majorité que je représente
droite centre et indépendants se trouve
bien placé dans une bonne partie des
cantons
on nous dit également que le dans votre
département comme ailleurs le
rassemblement national serait en recul
par rapport à 2015 est ce que vous avez
des informations qui confirmera ces
éléments alors je n'ai pas à ces
informations sur le plan départemental
je vous le dis très sincèrement par
contre sur mon territoire
il ya effectivement une baisse du
rassemblement national
donc je pense que si nous ne sommes pas
le baromètre mais je pense que c'est ce
que l'on voit d'ailleurs au niveau des
régions et je pense qu'effectivement il
ya une légère baisse de ce parti merci
patrick gendraud donc je vais reprendre
la main juste pour vous dire que à
l'heure où nous parlons il est 20h30 6
d'habitude on sait à peu près tout comme
résultat dans les départements dès 19h
mais on l'avait pas dit parce qu'ils ont
des vestaires jusqu'à 20 heures
on n'avait pas dit par exemple en 2015
que le département du jura bascule est
de gauche à droite par exemple mais là
nous avons très peu de résultats
mais comme donc le suspense est
insoutenable pour cette départementale
je donne la parole à gabriel et après je
la reprends pour vous donner le seul et
unique canton que j'ai gagné à vous en
avez vous des résultats alors ce n'est
pas beaucoup plus que vous et catherine
journée qu'un également un résultat qui
nous vient de saône et loire de saône et
loire avec le le canton d'uri ni un
canton qui était en fait jusque-là
détenu donc par la gauche et la sortante
catherine fargeau qui a été battu et
c'est le se sont fait un binôme
divers-droite patrick des roches et
karine lalanne qui arrive en tête avec
42 points 59 % et en deuxième position
donc catherine boulay et patrick monin
de la gauche 71
oui donc il y aura un deuxième tour
dimanche prochain
alors moi le canton que j'ai c'est celui
de villersexel en haute-saône automne
villersexel donc là le c'était un canton
qui appartenait
si j'ose dire à la gauche et les deux
binômes le gérard pelletant rennes
notamment et sabrina floraux ne se
représentait pas et actuellement
donc il y à bien un ballottage pour
dimanche prochain on peut constater que
c'est isabelle géa et michèle richard
qui sont tous les deux des républicains
qui arrive en tête avec 37% des voix
barbara bockstael et patrick vous arrive
en deuxième position ils sont qualifiés
eux aussi pour le deuxième tour dimanche
prochain
barbara bockstael c'est la nouvelle
maire de villersexel donc le
rassemblement national est battu dans le
canton de villers sexuelle et c'est ça
qui est tout à fait étonnant en effet
pour le peu de résultats que nous avons
il peut tendance que nous avons on
constate que le rassemblement national
contrairement à ce que nous disaient les
sondages semblent en recul même pour les
départementales et on a vu également que
pour les régionales mais ce n'était pas
tout à fait comme on nous avait annoncé
julien odoul dans un fauteuil en
première position
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué ce
soir notamment à cause de l'abstention
parce qu'il est très difficile quand il
ya aussi peu de votants d'arrivée
justement à des résultats qui sont
conformes aux prévisions puisqu'il ya
très peu de citoyens qui se sont
déplacés aux urnes
je laisse maintenant la parole à resa
pour le plateau des régionales en vous
retrouvant dans la deuxième tranche de
décrochage en espérant qu'on aura
beaucoup beaucoup plus de résultats
à vous communiquer à tout à l'heure et
zaz katerine et gabriel merci à vous on
va ici sur le plateau des régionales
vous redonner ce sondage ipsos steria
avec vous gérez me pose est fort
mattotti oui c'est pas c'est pas un
résultat définitif pour les régionales
mais c'est un sondage sortie des urnes
ipsos steria et c'est marc guide dufay
la présidente socialiste sortante qui
basculerait en tête de ce premier tour
ce soir 26,2 % des suffrages
elle devancerait le candidat du
rassemblement national julien odoul
autour de 23 8% puis juillet gilles
platret des républicains à 20 9% enfin
denis thuriau 12 7% de 10 thuriau le
candidat la république en marche suivent
stéphanie modde juste en dessous de l
barre des 10% puis bastien photo 4,1
pour cent et enfin claire rocher 2 4%
olivier damien vous étiez plutôt
confiant rassemblement national depuis
quelques semaines rien n'est fait c'est
la conclusion de ce signe frappes
soudain très clair c'est une élection
les sondages nous les avons pris pour ce
qu'ils étaient il est clair que nous
savions que le contexte allait être très
compliqué nous avons vu dans quelles
conditions lamentables
ces élections ont été organisées donc il
était évident ça c'est pour toujours
aimé oui mais pour pour tout le monde il
n'en demeure pas moins que c'est la
démocratie qui en prend un coup
quels que soient les partis on est bien
d'accord on est bien d'accord mais ce
soir c'est particulièrement le
rassemblement national comme aux
dernières municipales d'ailleurs qui
pâtit de l'abstention contexte contexte
sensiblement identique
alors moi je pense que nous nos forces
sont encore disponibles soyons très
clairs
on fera le point la semaine prochaine
c'est vrai que si le résultat se
confirme et nous placent en deuxième
position et mais il faut que les
électeurs du rassemblement national et
tous ceux qui veulent véritablement du
changement dans cette région viennent
voter dimanche prochain
et à partir de là on verra comment les
choses se passent mais je crois une fois
encore que l'organisation de ces
élections
le contexte sanitaire ne sont pas pour
rien cette forte abstention forcément à
pénaliser à plaisir de notre formation
merci merci beaucoup monsieur damien
d'ailleurs sont venus réagir aux
résultats du rassemblement national nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau claire mallard
d'europe écologie les verts on a vu la
liste de stéphanie modde buteraient sur
la barre sur le seuil des 10% qui permet
de se qualifier pour le second tour est
ce que vous êtes déçu il ya plusieurs
enseignements fait je crois sur c'est
sur cette élection et j'ai envie de
prendre le temps quand même de de
m'exprimer sur ces choses l'effondrement
de la participation je crois que en tant
que démocrate
on est tous peinés en fait de cette
faible participation qui est historique
je crois qu'il va falloir quand même
avoir une réflexion de fond sur les
causes qui fait que deux scrutins
scrutin on arrive à ce à ce genre de
situation donc réfléchissons ensemble et
je crois qu'à un moment donné c'est
plutôt nabeul cette défiance
et si ce qui se passe par rapport à la
halle le manque de lisibilité sans doute
des politiques publiques
je pense aux régionales et
départementales qui fait qu' elles n'ont
pas donné sans doute assez envie aux
citoyens de se déplacer ce que c'est pas
la faute des candidats ah bah non je ne
vous expliquer que en fait il ya un
contexte est structurel c'est quelque
part un peu l'échec de la loi nôtre on
n'a pas réussi à clarifier les
compétences et comment les gens s'y
retrouvent entre des compétences qui
sont pas claires c'est parce qu'on se
moque de l'est d'abord si la pédagogie
new media
ah bah je n'accuse personne voilà je
veux dire c'est que à un moment donné
c'est plutôt les responsables politiques
est ce qu on se satisfait aujourd'hui
d'avoir un mille feuille territorial de
la sorte avec un manque de compétences à
manque de lisibilité sans doute de
l'action publique qui est à notre avis
sans doute peu mobilisant ça c'est une
première chose a rejoint sur ce label
que je vais vous après pour expliquer
convaincre didier paris ce porte parole
denis thuriau pour la république en
marche nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
peut-être déjà un premier mot si vous
voulez réagir à cette abstention cette
participation en chute libre vous êtes
surpris on assiste à une situation
prévisible mais pas à ce point quand
même de ce que le premier parti de
france est clairement celui des
abstentionnistes
et c'est une catastrophe pour moi
largement au delà du résultat de telle
ou telle partie la catastrophe
démocratique
elle est quand même là le fait que nos
concitoyens ne se soit pas ou peu
déplacé pour un scrutin qui pourtant est
essentiel même s'ils n'ont pas toujours
où tous ou tant mieux parce qu'on a
entendu depuis le début de cette foire
électorale c'était que c'était en gros
la faute du gouvernement qui avait
choisi cette date et qui avait choisi un
opérateur privé pour distribuer le
matériel électoral
on sait qu'il ya peut-être jusqu'à la
moitié des électeurs qui n'ont pas reçu
et les bulletins de vote et les
professions de foi avant le genre de
vote mais je pense qu'il ya une
multitude de causes en réalité peut-être
celle ci en font partie mais relative
complexité de ce scrutin double scrutin
au même moment après le choix de le
choix de le faire à ce moment-là si si
ils avaient été repoussés j'aurais nous
aurions entendu tous les partis les bras
tout la corde
surtout la droite dire oh c'est un
scandale
mocratie fallait rien au pouce et donc
aurait-il fallu le faire j'en sais rien
le résultat ils l'avouent par les deux
de l'opérateur privé adrexo pour ne pas
le citer parce que c'est vrai qu'on est
en limite de rupture d'un fonctionnement
normal
comment est ce possible que environ 40%
du territoire de bourgogne franche comté
n'est pas été distribuées pour les
professions de foi moi j'ai rencontré ce
matin en allant voter
deux dames qui était devant moi je n'ai
discuté avec m qu'après paravent
évidemment les deux dames qui me disait
je ne sais pas pour qui voter en arrière
russie on n'a pas eu le temps de
regarder on ne sait pas normal c'est
effectivement pas normal je pense que
l'état vrais savent ce qu'ils pouvaient
faire
il a fait un appel d'offres c'est une
les raisons moche je voudrais pas qu'on
simplifient à l'excès les ce processus
qui est quand même plus complexe c'est
une des raisons mais elle a pu jouer
aussi est la plus jouée le problème une
politique que nous rencontrons c'est que
qui est défavorisée quand on est une
abstention elle c'est évidemment les
parties je dirais raisonnable c'est pas
les extrêmes
le parti qui pâtit le plus par rapport à
2015 c'est le rassemblement national
alors je sais pas si ça rend par la
catégorie sans citer sa politique sans
doute pour d'autres raisons d' analyse
politique et j'ai un peu le sentiment
que ma stratégie de gilles platret a été
payante
en la matière c'est à dire qu'il a
ponctionné des voix au rassemblement
national il ya peu de doute là dessus à
mon avis alors je vous propose qu'on
écoute monsieur pâris la réaction de
votre tête de liste denis thuriau qui
s'est exprimé il y à quelques minutes en
direct depuis la préfecture de dijon on
écoute de nature you il faut prendre le
temps de la réflexion voilà un résultat
des régionales c'est pour ma part la
première fois je le vis j'ai toute une
équipe
on est sans cesse comme ici au total
donc pour l'instant je suis dans la
réflexion
j'attendais la française avait dans
détendre un peu j'attendais vraiment
d'avoir des chiffres précis parce que
j'étais important d'avoir ces chiffres
là les miens comme ceux des autres avant
de prendre des sens défini
il voit là on veut toujours faire mieux
maintenant ça n'est pas rien non plus
nous sommes au deuxième tour donc nous
allons voir la stratégie que nous
prônons au deuxième tour soutenir le
président sortant
réponse demain matin au plus tard dès
maintenant parce que je suis pas tout
seul je maniais des clips et que nous
attendions d'avoir sait si vous
comprenez bien que c'est pas le problème
des 3e 4e le prince et à combien on est
des autres et ce qui peut se passer en
fonction du choix que l'on fait de se
maintenir ou pas donc pour moi pour
l'instant la décision sera prise au plus
tard demain matin didier parisse la
décision demain matin ce parce que vous
attendez les consignes de paris non je
pense qu'il est normal et naturel
un mouvement politique qui va pas faire
des allers-retours avec avec paris c'est
normal mais c'est pas ça qui nous si
vous avez bien écoutez denis curieux et
parle pas de paris par simplement une
situation qui me paraît absolument
simple normal bon on regarde le résultat
pour l'instant ce ne sont que des
prévisions
j'ai vu les résultats au fur et à mesure
de la rentrée des des commandes et des
dépouillements
est ce qu'on sera à 12 à 12 7 comme vous
le prévoyez a trait à 13,5 ça peut
changer la donne premiers éléments
deuxième élément comme l'a très
justement dit nos têtes de listes denis
curieux on a fait un super boulot
ensemble si je peux me permettre c'est
qu' il n'y a pas qu'un candidat y en a
cent seize mérite un peu de réflexion il
sera toujours temps demain matin de
prendre une position après les quelques
compositions personnelles c'est examiner
hausse était de céder la majorité
présidentielle s'est pas seulement de
débuter ses directeurs de campagne au
seuil de liste du département
c'est exactement ce que je viens de vous
dire si nous avons besoin de faire une
analyse enfin je comprends que les
médias est en cours
vous devez comprendre qu'on attend un
tout petit peu plus maintenant et ma
mère à l'enfant avant mardi 18h ceci est
absolument vous ai raison c'est un
honneur qui ne nous a pas échappé
et vous comprenez qu'on ait besoin de
cette année est ce que je pourrais dire
peut-être pour faire avancer un peu
votre réflexion c'est que nous n'avons
jamais une autre posture que saic de
l'ouverture est celle du dialogue
ouverture guivalogui c'est à dire qu'on
verra comment les choses se déroulent
nous ne souhaitons pas voir arriver et
ça reste une comptant une constante
l'extrême droite
je tends d'exploitation au nom du
rassemblement national nous ne
souhaitons pas à voir arriver
l'extrême droite dans notre belle région
et donc voilà la nouvelle ce week end
ensoleillé des éléments un très beau
livre moi ce que j'entends c'est qu'une
élection à deux tours se gagne au
deuxième tour il le risque du
rassemblement national
il n'est pas évacuée il baisse beaucoup
par rapport à la dernière fois nous
montons c'est un fait mais vu la
stratégie qui a été mise en place
notamment par la droite d'essayer de
pompey l'électorat du front national en
se positionnant assez largement sur ses
idées
comment vont se comporter ces électeurs
deuxième tour et moi je suis extrêmement
vigilant c'est pas parce qu'on est donc
vous êtes prêt à discuter avec la
république on marche je souhaite que
nous soyons le rempart définitif au
front avec la reine je souhaite si la
reine veut nous apporter son soutien
mais elle a la possibilité de faire
baisser elle veut apporter des candidats
la question d'apporter des candidats
c'est la question de l'analyse des
résultats c'est la question d'un rapport
de la porte n'est pas fermée
c'est la question d'un rapport de force
politique et ça n'est pas la position
première de la présidente de région qui
a dit y rassemble la gauche et des
écologistes d'abord c'est la position
constante depuis le début mais nous
voulons avant tout faire barrage au
front national le risque n'est pas
complètement évacué on doit se
satisfaire de ce reflux
et si la république en marche prend la
décision de se retirer complètement
eh bien ça nous aidera naturellement
mais je comprends que chacun attende les
résultats définitifs
free à nous on veut continuer le travail
de défense des habitants de bourgogne
franche comté
nous voulons continuer à faire prospérer
ce bilan on n'est pas dans les petits
arrangements on veut juste continuer à
travailler sereinement
eh bien je crois pour les pour les
habitants de bourgogne franche claire
mallard est-ce que la république en
marche est une ligne rouge pour les
écologistes en vue du deuxième tour
nous ce que l'on construit depuis
plusieurs mois c'est de mobiliser
l'électorat écologiste et d'une écologie
forte en bourgogne franche comté et je
crois qu'on peut souligner ce soir quand
même excusez moi de le dire le retour
des écologistes dans la vie politique
régionale
quand même vous n'êtes pas encore sûrs
d'avoir des élus non mais on fait quand
même 9 % on y pu complètement exclue
comme on l'était en 2015
donc je souhaite quand même moins de 4 %
la liste menée par cécile quand même le
souligner ce soir ça c'est une première
chose je souligne aussi effectivement le
recul du front national quand même une
bonne nouvelle
on est bien d'accord et la chose que
nous construisons c'est un rassemblement
de la gauche et des autres et des
écologistes très très clairement et
après si monsieur pâris et la liste de
la république en marche prennent leurs
responsabilités parce que effectivement
je rejoins assez monsieur money noz et
envisage effectivement de soutenir en se
retirant conformément à alors à leurs
mots de mettre leurs mots en actes dans
le cadre de la lutte contre le front
national
on peut on ne pourra que souligner ça
c'est se retirer s'il vous demande
d'accepter des candidats sur une large
liste d'union nous aujourd'hui ce sur ce
quoi sur ce sur quoi on est engagée
c'est un rassemblement de la gauche et
des écologistes
et ça c'est un message et la république
en mars ce n'est pas la gauche pour
l'instant on a un scrutin où trois
droites un très clairement on a trois
droites qui sont là et il ya une
dynamique
aujourd'hui on le voit très clairement
les chiffres prévisionnels de 10 qui est
en faveur de la gauche et des
écologistes face à troyes droite qui
sont en incapacité de se les trois
listes de gauche atteint quasiment 40%
des suffrages
on voulait dire cela je voulais
simplement dire c'est qu'à travers
n'oubliez pas que nous sommes en
capacité à nous maintenir au deuxième
tour ce qui est pas le cas de toutes les
listes ici ou ailleurs nous sommes en
capacité de nous maintenir c'est aussi
un élément d'analystes que nous devons
faire raison pour laquelle nous ne
prenons pas de décision et quand on
parle de république au marché un peu un
propre c'est le modem c'est à sa demande
de 2,2
deux mouvements partenaires ce qui
complexifie aussi le niveau discussion
qui est nôtre puisque nous n'avons
jamais considéré que c'était une que
c'était une élection qui se mener seul
par contre nous avons considéré que
c'est une élection qui portait des
valeurs nous les avons portés nous avons
essayé de les exprimer bien ou mal mais
nous les avons exprimé et nous
souhaitons qu'elle perdure d'une manière
ou d'une autre
jean marie sermier est ce que vous
envisagez de vous rapprocher de la
république en marche comme on a pu voir
dans d'autres régions
écoutez ça fait quelques minutes que je
vous écoute et et je constate que vous
êtes en négociation un tripatouillage
exactement ce que les français ne
veulent plus nous on a une liste qui est
clair on est une liste qui sera
effectivement au deuxième tour on a une
liste qu on ne détruira pas pour des
petits arrangements politiques
on a une offre politique clair c'est le
renouvellement de cette région et nous
sommes la seule liste à pouvoir
permettre une alternance républicaine en
besogne en franche comté en vie car on
ne s'adresse pas on ne s'adresse pas au
parti on s'adresse aux électeurs
nous nous adressons aux électeurs de
bourgogne et de franche-comté en leur
disant effectivement nous sommes la
capacité à mobiliser nous sommes la
capacité de l'alternance venez nous
rejoindre
il ya un certain nombre d'électeurs qui
ne sont pas venus voter au cours de ce
premier tour de l'élection régionale
il va falloir mobiliser et je vous
assure d'ailleurs les dernières
estimations nous donne quelques points
de plus que vous nous donniez et bien je
vous assure que l'élection ils
commencent effectivement ce soir on va
faire des propositions chacun fera ses
propositions
certains j'ai bien compris vont essayer
de joindre la carpe et le lapin sur la
même liste
et y'a l'élection vous savez eric sion
il ya l'élection d'un président mais il
ya la gestion après pendant sept années
d'une collectivité capacité de très bien
jouer
je voulais dit tout à l'heure vous me
parler exclusivement du mandat précédent
moi je dis on attend l'avenir et je
confirme qu'il a changé et je vous dis
que le paysage électoral a changé
monsieur d'éviter de l'arrivée des solos
bande les cours doit permettre ou
bouclier humain fort que toi permet
d'avoir une réelle alternance et une
réelle efficacité
ce qui est loin d'être le cas et
aujourd'hui je constate tout simplement
que le risque de petit arrangement mais
qu'ils arrangent moi c'est le droit
c'est vous qui s'étaient enchaînés
si vous placez moi qui pose les
questions est ce que vous avez à thouars
jean marie sermier sur la neige ce qui a
été fait par plusieurs de vos
adversaires politiques ce soir c'est la
droite c'est votre liste qui a fait
baisser le front national en mordant et
en faisant campagne sur les thèmes du
rassemblement national
mais aujourd'hui on s'adresse à tous les
électeurs à tous les bourguignons et
tous les francs comtois est donc
aujourd'hui si un certain nombre
d'électeurs qui votait traditionnement
traditionnellement et rennes front
national avant nous ont rejoints je
trouve que c'est plutôt intéressant pour
la démocratie est ce qu a sélectionné la
démocratie c'est parce que vous avez
parents sont effectivement vers une
alternative républicaine
est ce que vous estimez vous que si vous
êtes vous avez pris des voix au
rassemblement national c'est parce que
vous avez fait une alliance avec debout
la france je crois qu'on rassemble
largement on nous parle effectivement de
debout la france et nous assumons très
clairement les choses mais on est aussi
avec lui dit ça ne vous aura pas échappé
à personne reste de l'année et de lui
dit qu'ils avaient eux mêmes faire
michel zumkeller qui est en charge de
lui des ide en dans ce futur de
bourgogne franche comté et vous allez
s'il y en a du coup c'est que j'espère
bien saisi des candidats ils sont
adhérents modem
donc je veux dire 1,9 mais oui mais donc
quand on nous parle dans le dos moi je
vous parle aussi du mauvais vin défroqué
aussi des chasseurs je vous parle un
certain nombre de deux personnes qui
nous ont rejoint la société civile et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en
capacité faire une proposition
les écologistes raisonnable de monsieur
waechter nous ont rejoint également vous
ai posé des affiches et sonel
vous êtes aussi affiché avec nadine
morano qui clairement à a dit qu'elle
souhaitait travailler avec le
rassemblement national jusqu'aux grandes
moi je voudrais bien rebondir hausse à
l'isic armes alors vraiment c'est
important je crois qu'à un moment donné
on peut pas constater dire on a une
crise démocratique et récurrentes et
salir les scrutins de liste à la
proportionnelle à deux tours
on a la chance quand même de pouvoir à
ce que les électeurs puissent s'exprimer
au premier tour et qui est une offre
politique c'est ce qu'on appelle du
pluralisme démocratique est en fait
c'est une élection de temps il ya deux
élections en une on a un premier tour
qui se joue et 1 seconde
donc arrêtons de dire de façon
démagogique qui a des tripatouillages
non il ya une expression du pluralisme
démocratique au premier tour et les
techniques de secours et d'aidé la vivre
second tour qui se joue et il faut
arrêter de débours les deux aussi accusé
ne l'aiment pas la démocratie c'est pas
comme ça que nos citoyens pour ma part
je vais voter c'est normal que entre
aujourd'hui et mardi vous ayez une
négociation mais vers sur mes pierre
mais faire renter paul giacobbi voir
encore que vous aviez bien ces petits
jeux vous laisser le monde c'est
rarissime et s'il vous plaît laissez le
répondre est atterrant passe à autre
chose en avance je servier c'est pas
sérieux vous parlementaires et pas si
vous avez quelques notions de droit
constitutionnel vous avez quelques
notions de comment on organise
l'élection est effective et que les
électeurs sur le terrain
non merci messieurs je vous propose de
faire une petite pause on va poursuivre
notre tour des quartiers généraux va
retrouver vincent collet vincent collet
qui se trouve avec l'équipe de dawn
iturrioz on écoute ici à la préfecture
de région la liste du candidat lrm de
dénis thuriau est pour l'instant crédité
de 11,6 pour cent des suffrages
un chiffre
avec des passes est il ne s'agit que de
résultats partiels les grandes villes
les résultats des grandes villes vont
encore arriver
trois chemins s'ouvrent en tout cas pour
le candidat de la république en marche
le premier est bien c'est le grand
espoir des macros nist même s'ils ne
disent pas explicitement c'est une
fusion avec la liste de marie-guite
dufay
reste à savoir si la candidate
socialiste sera ouverte aux négociations
deuxième option est bien un maintien pur
et simple avec une liste sur le même
format qu'au premier tour et troisième
option enfin le désistement une option
évidemment qui rebute le maire de nevers
et sa liste d'autant que d'après les
chiffres dont nous disposons à l'heure
actuelle la perspective d'une victoire
du candidat du rassemblement national
julien odoul semble s'éloigner car il
arriverait en deuxième position c'est
sans doute une longue nuit de réflexion
voire de négociation qui s'ouvre une
certitude
et ça nous a été répétée par denis
thuriau il n'y aura pas de décisions
rendues ce soir merci beaucoup vincent
collet en direct de claix la préfecture
à dijon jérémie on va peut-être donner
les chiffres de ce sondage sortie des
urnes ipsos steria partenaires de france
télévisions pour cette soirée électorale
marie-guite dufay basculerait est en
tête du premier tour avec 26,2 pour cent
des suffrages marie-guite dufay la
présidente socialiste sortante qui
devancerait dans l'ordre julien odoul du
rassemblement national gilles platret
les républicains et denis thuriau la
république en marche ses quatre listes
peuvent se maintenir pour le second tour
suivant stéphanie modde 9 9% bastien
photo est claire rocher de lutte
ouvrière
voilà et on va en discuter dans un petit
quart d'heure plus qu'on va se retrouver
juste après le décrochage national
francis letellier carole gaessler on
compte sur vous restez avec nous et à
tout à leur merci à tout de suite
[Musique]